How does a gene, which consists of a string
of DNA hidden in a cell's nucleus, know when
it should express itself?
How does this gene cause the production of
a string of amino acids called a protein?
How do different types of cells know which
types of proteins they must manufacture?
The answers to such questions lie in the study
of gene expression.
There are at least 3 levels of regulating
gene expression:
• transcriptional control (whether and how
much a gene is transcribed into mRNA)
• translational control (whether and how
much an mRNA is translated into protein)
• post-translational control (whether the
protein is in an active or inactive form,
and whether the protein is stable or degraded)
In transcription, the DNA within a gene codes
for an mRNA, which then undergoes post-transcriptional
modification.
Each end gets a special cap tacked on, like
the 5-prime cap, which is a modified guanine,
and the poly-A tail, which is 50 to 250 adenines.
Then, a protein complex called a spliceosome
will cut out sections called introns, and
other sections called exons come together
to form a smaller mRNA, which then moves from
the nucleus to the cytoplasm.
This is where translation occurs.
In translation, the mRNA, a ribosome, and
many tRNAs, work together to produce a polypeptide.
Some of these polypeptides will then be complete,
but others will instead undergo folding, likely
in the endoplasmic reticulum, and sometimes
post-transcriptional modification in the Golgi
apparatus, where groups like sugars, lipids,
or phosphates are attached.
Then the proteins are delivered to where they
need to go.
We know from learning about mitosis that every
cell in your body, except your gametes, contains
all of your genetic information, and therefore
all of your genes.
But different cells in your body serve different
purposes.
Some are muscle cells, some are nerve cells,
some are liver cells, so different cells need
to express different genes.
How does a cell know which genes to express
and which to leave dormant, so that it can
serve its particular purpose?
This is done through regulatory mechanisms.
These evolved very early in the timeline of
life on earth, because single-celled organisms
had an advantage if they only expressed the
genes that code for proteins that are needed
by the cell in a given moment.
If a particular resource that the organism
needs is plentiful nearby, it should stop
self-producing that substance to save energy.
If it is sparse in the environment, it needs
to kick start production to survive.
This kind of metabolic control is self-regulating,
because the products of certain enzymatic
pathways act as inhibitors for those pathways.
So if there is a lot of a certain metabolite
accumulating in a cell, it slows down the
pathway by which it is generated.
This is called feedback inhibition.
But how exactly does this work on the molecular
level?
Bacterial cells utilize operons to regulate
the gene expression.
Even though human cells are more complicated,
the concept of how it works is quite similar.
Let’s look at a particular metabolic pathway
present in the bacterial species E. coli.
The amino acid tryptophan is synthesized in
three steps, with each step catalyzed by a
different enzyme, and it takes a total of
five genes to produce these enzymes.
These genes are found very close to one another
on the bacterial chromosome, and a single
promoter serves them all, producing one huge
mRNA that produces all five enzymes during
translation, when ribosomes anneal at any
of the various start codons on the chain.
This means that these five genes are coordinately
controlled.
Any influence on the transcription of these
genes will impact the production of all of
these enzymes.
There is a segment of DNA, in this case in
between the promoter and the first gene, which
operates as an on-off switch.
This is called an operator, and it controls
whether RNA polymerase has access to transcribe
or not.
The promoter, the operator, and all these
genes, are all together called an operon.
Normally, the operon is on.
But something called a repressor can bind
to the operator, which then blocks access
to the promoter, so RNA polymerase can’t
do its job.
If the genes can’t be transcribed, the enzymes
can’t be produced, and the cell can’t
build tryptophan.
This repressor is specific to this operator,
so it doesn’t do anything to other genes,
and it is a protein, which is a product of
a different gene somewhere else in the DNA.
This tryptophan-specific repressor is produced
regularly, but in an inactive state that has
little affinity for the operator.
When tryptophan binds to the active site of
the repressor, it changes shape to become
an active form that has much more affinity
for the operator, so it will bind and stay
on for quite some time, thus turning the operon
off, inhibiting gene expression, and limiting
further tryptophan production.
The more tryptophan there is in the cell,
the more repressors that will be activated
to inhibit gene expression.
The less tryptophan there is, the less inhibition
there will be.
While we just saw an example where a gene
is typically on unless repressed, there are
also genes that are typically off, or silenced,
unless activated.
In E. coli, again, there are genes that when
expressed, produce an enzyme that will metabolize
lactose, a disaccharide, into individual monosaccharide
units, glucose and galactose.
There is typically a repressor bound to the
operator that corresponds to these genes,
but an isomer of lactose called allolactose
will bind to the repressor and deactivate
it, thus allowing for transcription of the
gene, enzyme production, and higher levels
of lactose metabolism.
These two examples both demonstrate negative
gene regulation.
One repressed gene expression, and the other
deactivated a repressor, so the signaling
molecules do not interact directly with DNA.
There can also be positive gene regulation,
where a signaling molecule like cAMP will
bind to a protein called an activator, which
will then bind to DNA and directly stimulate
gene expression by increasing the affinity
that RNA polymerase has for the promoter.
So negative and positive gene regulation are
both methods by which signaling molecules
interact with operators, repressors, and promoters
to regulate the frequency with which certain
genes are expressed.
Regulation gets more complicated than this,
however.
Many cells need to do more than respond to
levels of glucose or lactose.
When a fetus grows, cells are dividing and
becoming specialized, and each cell acquires
a distinct role on the basis of selective
gene expression.
Nerve cells and liver cells and skin cells
are very different from one another, even
though they all possess the same genetic material,
and the secret behind this is strict regulation
of gene expression.
In any given cell, some genes are expressed,
and some aren’t.
An easy way to turn genes on and off has to
do with the way that DNA is wrapped around
histones to form nucleosomes.
When bound to histones, genes can’t be expressed.
In order to express a gene, the gene must
become accessible.
This can happen if an enzyme modifies a histone
through acetylation, methylation, or phosphorylation,
thus decreasing its affinity for DNA.
When a gene is no longer coordinated to the
histone, it is available for transcription.
In order for transcription to proceed, proteins
called transcription factors are necessary.
Some of these bind to a section of a promoter,
usually in a region called a TATA box, as
thymine-adenine pairs are easier to pry apart,
given that they make one fewer hydrogen bonds
than a CG pair.
Binding to DNA occurs due to a binding domain
that has affinity for a specific sequence
of nucleotides in the promoter.
The transcription factor also has an activation
domain, which will bind to other regulatory
proteins that enhance transcription.
A transcription factor can have one or more
of either of these types of domains.
In addition, there are other control elements
farther away from the gene called enhancers
that interact with proteins called activators.
When activators bind to the enhancer, another
protein can bend DNA to bring the activators
closer to the promoter where the transcription
factor can be found.
Other proteins mediate interactions that produce
the complete transcription initiation complex,
which allows RNA polymerase to do its job.
So, we can see that transcription is quite
a bit more complex than we previously discussed.
There are many proteins involved when any
gene is being transcribed, and so regulation
of the levels of these proteins can regulate
the expression of other genes.
Some genes can only be transcribed when specific
activator proteins are present, and this may
only occur at a specific time, like hormones
carrying a message to promote the expression
of genes whose products trigger development
during puberty.
Combined with the acetylation and deacetylation
of histones to either activate or silence
genes, proteins that bind to mRNA to prevent
translation, and other phenomena, the cell
has several strategies at its disposal to
regulate gene expression.
A combination of these regulatory strategies
therefore allows a relatively small number
of inputs to regulate thousands of genes independently.
Although these interactions are much more
complex than we have depicted here, they tend
to follow these principles.